today on the matt walsh show the actress
ellen page has announced that she's
actually an actor
named elliot page she came out as a man
of course the media has been in a state
of rapturous
celebration over this but i have some
questions i think they're fair questions
i'll ask them today
also five headlines including chuck
schumer endorsing joe biden's plan to
force women to share the bathroom with
men and biden's treasury secretary
nominee
explains how she will use the treasury
to
heal racism heal sexism and fix climate
change
finally today breathing is canceled this
was not my decision usa today
canceled breathing in a recent op-ed and
it's my duty to share the news with you
which i will
today all of that and more on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well before we get going here today you
know we all love underdog
stories i think that's one of the things
that makes us american we all love
stories like that
the story of america in many ways in its
origins is an underdog story
and that's why i can't recommend enough
the true underdog
podcast you know raised in a trailer
park with no clear path to
success kicked out of high school
multiple times faced with becoming a
father and his teens jason waller
is the definition of a true underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with
his most recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar enterprise
you could join um waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner
as he shares his motivational tips and
inspiring stories
and business building lessons from the
ground up he shares his life experiences
and that of his high profile guests
to help others better themselves so you
can follow the same path have the same
success
um and have the same underdog story as
waller tells you about you know there's
there's no
elevator to success the climb happens
one step at a time you gotta
put the work in and what you can learn
about from this podcast you learn about
failure failure you learn about
entrepreneurship you learn about
never quitting making never making
excuses it's a very real very raw
and also motivational podcast cannot
recommend it enough check out true
underdog podcast
at trueunderdog.com or anywhere you get
your podcasts
so there was celebration yesterday
confetti was thrown
champagne was poured tears of joy were
wept
when the actress ellen page revealed
that she is a man
named elliot yes apparently it seems
ellen page who has been a woman for 33
years of life
is actually a man she says and for this
urgent news bulletin as always
we'll go to people magazine here's their
report
elliot page is living his truth and
coming out as transgender
paige formerly known as ellen released a
heartfelt statement on twitter tuesday
writing in part quote
i want to share with you that i am trans
my pronouns are he they
and my name is elliot paige added i feel
lucky to be writing this
to be here to have arrived at this place
in my life the 33 year old known for his
oscar-nominated role in the film juno
goes on to express overwhelming
gratitude for those who have supported
his journey adding quote
i can't begin to express how remarkable
it feels to finally love who i am enough
to pursue my authentic self
paige also asks fans for patience in the
statement explaining that his joy is
fragile and that he is scared of
invasiveness
hate jokes and violence he also
addresses the discrimination against the
trans community
calling it insidious and cruel resulting
in horrific consequences
according to page's post in 2020 alone
it has been reported that at least
40 transgender people have been murdered
he adds that the majority of those
victims have been black and latinx trans
women
paige also calls out political leaders
who continue to criminalize trans
healthcare
and deny individuals their right to
exist he states that those who spew
hostility towards the trans community
have blood on their hands because 40 of
trans adults report attempting suicide
paige goes on to directly address trans
people who deal with a quote
threat of violence every day saying he
sees and loves them
and promises that he will do everything
he can to change this world for the
better
last year paige revealed that he married
dancer emma portner who reposted this
statement on her instagram tuesday
writing in the caption that she is proud
of paige and calling his existence
a gift in and of itself okay everything
you heard at the end there was
completely false actually it was all
completely false especially the part
where she said her authentic self is a
man but
the claim that trans people are the
victim of a hate crime epidemic has
simply no evidence to support it there
is a similar lack of evidence to support
the claim
that health care for trans people is
being criminalized
and that trans people are being denied
the right to exist
there's only one group of people in this
country who are denied the right to
exist and they're still in the womb
the pro-abortion page doesn't care about
that group though of course
she'd rather fight imaginary injustices
than real ones
speaking of imaginary especially
imaginary injustices you may recall a
couple years ago ellen page
on tv with stephen colbert blaming mike
pence
for the hate crime that jesse smollette
committed against himself
it's worth revisiting that rant i think
because it raises an interesting
question listen
i'm like really fired up tonight this is
how this is how you have to be fired it
feels impossible to not feel this way
right now with the president and the
vice president mike pence who like
wishes i couldn't be married
let's just be clear the vice president
of america wishes i didn't have the love
with my wife he wanted to ban that in
indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana and i think the
thing we need to know and i hope my show
vacation did this
in terms of connecting the dots in terms
of what happened the other day did you
say i don't know him personally i saw
i send all of my love
connect the dots this is what happens if
you are in a position of power
and you hate people and you want to
cause
suffering to them you go through the
trouble you spend your career
trying to cause suffering what do you
think is going to happen
kids are going to be abused and they're
going to kill themselves
and people are going to be beaten on the
street
i have traveled the world and i have met
the most marginalized people you can
meet
i am lucky to have this time and the
privilege to say this
this needs to stop okay leaving aside
the rather
stupefying fact that ellen page was
somehow trying to blame the vice
president for the fact that two
imaginary men beat up an actor in
chicago while he was walking to subway
at 2 a.m and subzero temperatures
we we do have to ask one question ellen
page was referring to her own same-sex
lesbian marriage to another woman
now with this revelation that she's a
man named elliot
does that mean she was never really a
lesbian was she a straight white male
this whole time
and if so does that mean a straight
white male was playing all those roles
in all those films that
should have gone to real women does she
have to give back
all of the awards she's received for
best female lead in the film
well maybe all of the awards over states
a little bit but she has won a couple of
words i think at least
do those get returned or did she just
become a man now if so how did that
happen
and if she did just become a man doesn't
that mean she actually changed her
sexual orientation going from gay to
straight
isn't that impossible haven't we been
told that's impossible
by the way mere nano seconds after page
made the announcement her wikipedia
pages and imdb
imdb pages had been changed immediately
to
include the new pronouns lightning speed
this change was made
creepy enough but to make things weirder
paige's wikipedia page now if you go and
check it out
identifies her as a gay man married to a
woman
does that make sense how does it make
sense
these are just a few of the questions
that those who promote left-wing gender
theory
the theory that makes it possible
allegedly for ellen page to become a man
or be a man or to have always been a man
while also being a woman
cannot answer will not answer we're
meant to simply
accept that this woman is a man
even though nobody who makes the claim
including ellen herself can offer
any explanation of it they cannot tell
you
when she became a man how she became a
man how any of this is possible
scientifically or logically
in fact the people making the claim
cannot even so much as explain
what the claim actually is think about
that for a moment
ellen page says she's a man okay
what does she mean by that with all
these people announcing that they're
really a gender other than the one that
they were quote assigned at birth
the crazy thing is that nobody ever
stops to ask the simplest
most basic question what do you mean
what do you mean that's a fair question
isn't it that's a it's not a transphobic
question or a question that authorizes
anyone or denies anyone the right to
exist
it's also not a question that shuts
anyone down or shouts them down
or censors them quite the opposite this
is a question that seeks to
understand that seeks even to
take the claim seriously but i cannot
understand you or take you seriously
if i don't even know what you mean so
ellen page says she's a man all right
what do you mean ellen or elliot what do
you mean that you're a man
in what sense are you a man how do you
define the word man
what is a man i'm a man myself always
have been as far as i know
and it's clear that ellen page is not
exactly like me i mean you could look at
ellen page and look at me and say well
there's a very clear difference here
there's even a difference of kind of
category it would seem
there are a number of very significant
differences between the two of us
differences that go all the way down to
the level of dna
chromosomes reproductive capabilities
bone structure muscle mass etc
it seems that we're both human certainly
but different kinds of humans
different categories of human now you
say now we're the same kind the same
category well again
then what kind is that explain that kind
define the category and it does no good
to say that the word
man is fluid or an artificial construct
or
that it has no fixed meaning because if
that's the case then it doesn't mean
anything to identify yourself
as one you may as well still call
yourself a woman then because the words
don't mean
anything you can't very well insist that
your identity as this particular thing
is important and fundamental and we all
have to respect it
and also insist that this particular
thing has no meaning and could be
anything
and is nothing but a social construct
you just you do see how those two
propositions are in direct contradiction
don't you
see i want to understand you i do
i just need you to explain what you mean
in a way that's coherent
no it's not that you owe me specifically
an explanation
but if you want to be understood then
you have to explain what you're saying
if you don't want to be understood then
what's the point of making the
announcement in the first place
you know i could stand up in front of
the whole world and say everyone i want
you to know
i am a who's he whatsit that's what i am
that's how i identify if i were to say
that the immediate response from the
world would be
you're a what now what's that what's a
who'se watson what do you mean
i can't very well then respond well i
don't know you an explanation
stay out of my business i'm the one who
brought it up
the world didn't bring it up i did the
world is just trying to understand what
the hell i'm talking about
but of course when it comes to a woman
saying she's a man or a man saying he's
a woman
no one ever explained explains what's
that's supposed to mean
nobody ever explains anything related to
left-wing gender theory a theory that as
we've covered on this show was invented
about 70 years ago by a lunatic child
abuser named john money
who experimented on two young boys and
caused them both to kill themselves
he's the guy who came up with most of
what the left says about gender today
including the idea that a person can
have a gender that is at odds with their
biological sex
he came up with it this is his idea we
are meant now to simply accept and
believe and parrot these
ideas even if they make no sense and
even if the people making the claim
cannot themselves make sense of it
does it matter though that's the other
question
should we care you know many on the
right realize that left-wing gender
theory is nonsense they realize that men
are not women and women are not men they
realize that
this preferred pronoun stuff is absurd
you know they realize that you cannot
claim your own pronouns for yourself any
more than you can claim your own nouns
or prepositions
or your own adverbs doesn't make any
sense grammar doesn't work that way
language doesn't work that way
they realize all of this but they
retreat from the battle over these ideas
crawling under their beds to hide
while murmuring something about how this
is all a sideshow and it doesn't matter
that is the rationalization of a coward
yes it matters
the truth matters the truth in fact is
all that matters
it's the only thing that matters i don't
care about anything else but the truth
and i don't care to spend my time
defending anything else but the truth
the last gender ideology is among many
other things
all of them bad a direct assault on the
truth
they want to deny basic truth to build a
culture that denies it
to force you to deny it and that matters
it matters a lot it's also an assault on
children
our children your children gender
confusion is an epidemic among kids
today many lives are being destroyed by
we talked about this last
last week as well and we've talked about
this many times because it matters
other conservatives and many other
conservatives with platforms pretend it
doesn't matter but it does
the left wants to infuse confusion into
your child's mind they want to rob
your child of his understanding of
himself
they're trying to take from him what is
most basic most essential
most needed for a happy and healthy life
does that matter
i can think of very few things that
matter more
so yes we do need to say
it is important to say that ellen page
can change her name fine she's elliot
now that's fair you can you can be
whatever name you want to be
but she cannot be a man she's not a man
she will never be one and i say that not
because i'm trying to hurt her feelings
or deny her right to exist
but just because it's true and the truth
matters
now let's get to our five headlines
well speaking of gender madness chuck
schumer
was um asked yesterday about joe biden's
plan to let men
into the women's restroom and here's how
that conversation went
joe biden said that on his first day of
office he will give
transgender students access to sports
bathrooms and locker rooms in accordance
with their gender identity in all
federally funded schools
do you think he has the ability to do
this and do you agree with this decision
i agree with the decision
and i know he'll check things out
thoroughly legally yeah um
so this is uh to get men into the
women's restroom
is a top priority now for joe biden and
guys like chuck schumer they're fully on
board with it oh yeah
first day in office this is this is a
first day priority to make sure we get
the dudes into the women's bathroom
very very very important stuff now the
question i always ask
um with w when this when this comes up
especially coming from
someone like chuck schumer and joe biden
chuck schumer and joe biden both of them
decrepit ancient old men okay these guys
are
are in their upper 90s i believe and
they've been in public life forever
decades and decades right they'd never
mentioned this before
so right now for joe biden who's been
trying to be president for like 50 years
um and now he says first day in office
he's got to get he's got to get
women into men into the women's restroom
why don't you ever mention that before
as a priority
decades of public service if we can call
it that
never once mentioned it someone could
fact check me on this
and go back if you can find an example
of chuck schumer
or joe biden in you know i don't know
1997 or something or
any time prior to about 2012
saying anything about gender
transgender women men in the women's
room
then let me know i've looked i haven't
seen it as far as i could tell they
never once men once mentioned it now
it's a top priority
so the question always is okay you're
you're uh you're 78 years old
um you decided i don't know maybe around
the age of 70
that actually men can be women and that
it's okay to have men in the women's
restroom what changed your mind i mean
you live
70 years apparently completely confident
that men have penises and women have
vaginas and
around the age of 70 you changed your
mind that that's that is quite a
flip-flop isn't it
we're always talking about politicians
who flip-flop on issues i can't think of
an
i cannot think of a more profound a a
bigger more shocking flip-flop than this
you flip-flopped on the issue of whether
or not men have vaginas
essentially so why it's a question the
media never asks
how did you decide this what convinced
you
what scientific evidence did you see
well we all know the answer of course
these are men without spines these are
men
without anything going on these are men
without substance
and so they saw that the winds were
shifting that way and so
they they shifted with it we know that's
the real answer but i would love it if
one day they would
have to give some kind of answer because
they're not going to say that even
though it's true
number two janet yellen joe biden's
treasury secretary pick
has revealed what she plans to do with
the position and here's what she said
about that
we risk missing the obligation to
address deeper structural
problems inequality stagnant wages
especially for workers who lack a
college education
communities that have seen industry
disappear
with no good jobs replacing lost ones
racial disparities in pay job
opportunities
housing food security and small business
lending
that deny wealth building to communities
of color
gender disparities to keep women out of
the workforce
and keep our economy from running at
full
force it's a convergence of
tragedies that is not only economically
unsustainable
but one that betrays our commitment to
giving every american
an equal chance to get ahead
but i know this team will never give up
that commitment
as you've said before mr president-elect
out of our collective pain as a nation
we will find collective purpose to
control the pandemic
and build our economy back better than
before
to rebuild our infrastructure and create
better jobs
to invest in our workforce to advance
racial equity and make sure the economic
recovery
includes everyone to address the climate
crisis
with american ingenuity and american
jobs
okay sorry that was that was too long i
i can't even react to that because i
couldn't stay awake for it
um that's one thing about these
bureaucrats they just speaking of having
no substance
just put you right to sleep and that's
how they get away with doing a lot of
the stuff they're doing
what you just heard there was radical
but it was said in such a in
in such a such an intolerably dry and
boring way
that you you can't stay awake for it to
listen to
what their actual plans are and so you
just kind of want to wave at them and
say fine do whatever you want just stop
talking please
um in reality though she's talking about
you know using the treasury to fix
climate change how they're going to do
that of course
it's not possible but um this is this is
another thing this is another
another another promise that joe biden
has made he's going to stop hurricanes
he's going to fix the weather can't
explain how he's going to do it but he's
going to do it
going to stop gender disparities women
not in the workforce by the way
if you want to know in most cases
you know women who are not in the
workforce my wife for example not in the
workforce
okay so someone like janet yellen and
other democrats will look at that as a
problem
and they see that my wife is not in the
workforce they say we got to do
something to get to get this woman into
the workforce
you know why she's not in the workforce
because she doesn't want to be
she could be it's it's
pretty much anyone can get into the
workforce if they want to it's not hard
to get into the workforce
the the the the sacred hallowed
workforce
it may surprise especially democrats to
learn especially feminists
not everybody wants that my wife doesn't
want to be in the workforce
she wants to be at home with the kids
raising kids so that's what she's doing
you know that's that explains a lot of
the quote gender disparities
whether it's less women in the work
fewer women in the workforce i should
say
um or you know women in in jobs that
don't pay as much
it's because they make different choices
and those choices are great
those choices are more than fine they're
great in my opinion
but it's their choice to call that a
problem
i would say seems rather presumptuous to
say the least
number three barack obama in an
interview with stephen colbert
wants us to imagine if you can imagine
this a fantasy world
where democrats question the results of
an election
uh pretty pretty wild stuff but here he
is listen
you imagine the super bowl and
you know the game's going on and
touchdowns are supposed to be worth
six points with the extra point unless
you go for two and field goals are worth
three points and
you're keeping score the whole time and
the refs and so forth and then at the
end of the game
a team's won and somebody says
no field goals aren't worth three
or that wasn't really a touchdown well
hugo chavez
we've all been watching and i guess if
you had
the other team just refused to
acknowledge it and
you had half the league say
we're not sure it's true um you'd have a
similar controversy but
when that starts happening the game
itself breaks down
right the the and in in this case it's
not a game it's our democracy
our democracy starts falling apart
imagine if going forward
every single election is treated this
way
at every level imagine if democrats
start
acting this way uh is that part of the
danger that he's broken the seal on that
idea
that is the concern that i think we all
have it's
joe biden's going to be the next
president kamala harris is going to be
the next vice president but but we don't
want to get into a pattern where we just
uh are are willing to
throw out what we've agreed to
previously
including our constitutional structure
just because we find it politically
expedient
my god these people are just shameless
just shameless oh
imagine if democrats didn't accept the
results of an election
hard to imagine i mean they've only done
that for every
major election in in recent memory
other than that really difficult to
imagine they only spent
four years claiming that the that
president president trump's election was
illegitimate and he's a russian
spy sent here by putin to destroy the
country he only spent four years
claiming that they only tried to impeach
him
based on that with no evidence
hillary clinton has been on tv
for four years the woman can't get past
it get over it
um saying that trump is an illegitimate
president those words exactly
election was stolen those words exactly
but of course barack obama and this this
is what you get from the left always
they
just expect you to they're they're just
going to wave away reality and say no
that's not reality
you you you yeah we're not nope
you can't acknowledge that didn't happen
you think it happened but it didn't
just like ellen page you thought she was
a woman she's not
just nope stop asking questions stop
asking questions
all right this is from usa today um
let's see my producer sent me this one
uh about the mcrib how far would you go
for a free mcrib
well first of all i wouldn't go far at
all i literally would not walk across
the room for one you
you could have a free one just right
across this room here and i wouldn't get
up
i would get up and walk out of the room
just i don't have to be anywhere near
something that tastes and smells like
stale dog food smothered in barbecue
sauce
not even barbecue sauce just just
basically ketchup and vinegar
which is part of the barbecue sauce but
not the whole thing
um anyway mcdonald's iconic barbecue
sandwich
returns to restaurants nationwide
beginning wednesday but before the
mcrib's arrival which mcdonald's has
dubbed the sauciest moment of the year
the fast food chain is giving away 10
000 free sandwiches to hungry fans
with its shave for mcrib sweepstakes
shave for mcrib sweepstakes
mcdonald's said in news release beard or
no beard prepare for the mcrib with a
shave
because anyone can participate from your
brother to your mother sister-in-law or
cousin's roommate
post a picture of your clean cleanly
shaven or baby smooth face on your
public twitter
or public instagram profile using shave
for mcrib
okay so there what in the hell is this
first of all how weird is it
what why do we just accept this speaking
of things we should be asking questions
about
they're trying to convince people to
shave and post it online
is this some sort of weird fetish from
the the mcdonald's marketing
some some some depraved fetishist works
for the mcdonald's marketing program
department and he uh he suggested this
he said you know what we should do we
should have people shave and post it
online
that'll be a great yeah that'll be a
great marketing campaign
people will love it i mean i'll love it
at least
uh but then on top of that this again is
is is anti-beard bigotry
why would it be the opposite of that
especially if this is supposed to be
barbecue no
it's fake barbecue so it's appropriate i
suppose you have to shave your beard and
be a fake man in order to eat it but
um if this is supposed to be real
barbecue real barbecued ribs if that's
what you're going for
then it should be the opposite it should
be grow a beard and will give you
barbecue as a reward you can eat this
manly meal
that meal now that you have the face of
a man rather than the face of an
overgrown child
i'm telling you i've i've been telling
you this for a long time that anti-beard
bigotry
is one of the last acceptable bigotries
and i think the most uh
the most sinister bigotry in our society
today
pretty infuriating um number five
finally
new details is from the daily wires as
new details have emerged about the
disappearance of a 10 to 12-foot
monolith
that mysteriously appeared in the utah
wilderness earlier this month
by the way with this monolith thing it's
it's weird how we all just decided to
call it a monolith
instead of like the the the poll the
podium something
we all just decided to go with monolith
it does it makes it sound more epic i
suppose so i guess that's why we're
doing that
four men removed the monolith and hauled
it away in eyewitness claims
ross bernards a 34 year old photographer
from colorado
told the newspaper that he went to the
site on friday hoping to get a glimpse
of the monolith
he said he saw how did he know where the
monolith was because i thought they
weren't telling us
the they were keeping it a secret about
where the monolith was for some reason
so this guy says he went he's a
photographer he said he saw
four men push the shiny structure to the
ground break it apart
and haul it away in a wheelbarrow then
he says
as they walked off with the pieces one
of them said leave no trace
i don't know i'm doubting this i i've
personally i've always wanted to be in a
situation where i could say to someone
unironically
leave no trace uh it sounds a little bit
too cinematic for me but
james newland who traveled with bernards
to the site gave more details
he said it must have been about 10 or 15
minutes at most for them to knock over
the monolith and pull it out
we didn't know who they were and we were
not going to do anything to stop them
cowards while bernard snapped no
pictures nuland reportedly grabbed a few
cell phone images of the men
but the cell phone images are are grainy
okay so this is a professional
photographer he goes all the way to the
monolith
he happens to get there at the same
moment where where mysterious men
are in the middle of the night uh
dragging it away he doesn't take any
pictures but his friend with a
somehow grainy uh
cell phone camera takes a picture
how do you get a what does he have a
flip phone from 2004
how do you even get grainy pictures on
cell phones anymore
um and then um let's see there was
there was a a another set of hikers who
who ricardo moreno and sierra van meter
went to the site on friday and what they
claim this
is uh one of the guys mourinho says we
believe we might be the first people to
come to the utah monolith and have it
not be here anymore unfortunately
but what we do see though is someone
wrote
by b word and clearly took a p on where
the monolith once stood
i don't know the mystery deepens so okay
so
they drag it away they say leave no
trace and yet they
they scrawled by on the sand and peed
i don't think these guys quite
understand what leave no trace means
so the mystery uh continues but i of
course i will i will
continue in my theory that obviously
this in some way involves
involves aliens i'm sure before we get
to our daily cancellation today
you know one of the themes uh i think we
go back to on this show a lot
is um is sort of what is what does it
mean to be a conservative
and uh what are you trying to conserve
uh what we're trying to conserve and
preserve america and what makes america
special um
and when you think about now the the the
nation the evils and the threats that
were faced um
that's why i want to tell you about amac
the association of mature american
citizens is the fastest growing
conservative group in america
you can join amac they give you access
to money-saving benefits
cutting-edge news and a great bi-monthly
magazine but more importantly
amac fights for you we know that a
socialist storm is brewing it's on the
horizon if you care about
our future like i do then join amac
today over two million conservatives
like you and me have already joined a
mac you should be one of them
stand with us by joining right now go to
amac dot
u s forward slash walsh that's a m a c
dot u s forward slash walsh uh the
benefits of a mac membership are great
but the cause i think is even greater
it's one that we all believe in
join today at amac dot us forward slash
walsh
and also um if you're not already a
daily wire member
now is the time to join because we've
got some amazing stuff that's right
around the corner
uh we say right around the corner i mean
very very soon starting this friday
december 4th the michael knowles show is
going five days a week
adding more content for our members to
enjoy we're adding the entire prageru
catalog to dailywire.com by the end of
the year we've already got
uh we've already got a bunch of prageru
stuff there that you can you can find
there are five minute videos
you can find the website right now the
candace owen show from prageru
and speaking of candice owens she'll be
joining the daily wire here in nashville
with a
brand new live studio audience show
which will be very exciting
we're building a lot of other stuff
we're doing you know we're launching our
first feature film we're building a new
investigative journalism
team so go outside the narrative come
over to dailywire.com
subscribe we're loud we're opinionated
we're having a good time
dailywire.com subscribe uh but i am not
having a good time
with this part of it the daily wire
christmas ornaments that i am
again forced to tell you about what i
would ask is listen if you guys care
about me at all
um just buy these damn things
and once they're all bought i won't have
to talk about it anymore
and i won't have to endure this
humiliation
um all the daily wire hosts plus god
king jeremy boring as santa's adorable
elves
made out of painted metal you can you
can
get those those ornaments there i can't
you know the the ornament of me
the it does capture my essence i have to
admit at least that much
but i still i still object
i object on moral grounds to this
yet i'm promoting it anyway because
they're paying me to
so text christmas to eight three four
zero zero to get your tree decorated
with these uh
wonderful ornaments they're going fast
so get yours now
please dear god i beg you let's get now
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel breathing
to be clear i'm not cancelling breathing
myself
i kind of like breathing personally most
of the time i actually enjoy breathing
unless i'm in a rest stop bathroom or
someplace similar like a
burger king but usa today in an op-ed
has canceled breathing no more breathing
it's not allowed the article written by
michael stern and which i'm pretty sure
is not parody
has this headline covid has turned
breathing into a deadly event
and all of us into potential serial
killers
now in a different time and place that
headline would be the kind of thing you
might hear if you work with paranoid
schizophrenics in the psych ward of a
hospital
but now it's the subject of an editorial
in a major american publication
and it gets worse so listen to this as
we read the article says as coronavirus
burns an exponential path of destruction
across the american terrain
an insidious blanket of shadow damage is
quietly unfurling in its name
it's not just the death and scarred
lungs kovan 19 has turned every man
woman and child
into a potential serial killer let's
let's just try to look past the
abysmal writing here i mean an insidious
blanket of shadow damage
that sounds like a lyric from a
dashboard confessional song in 2002
or maybe shadow damage could be the
title track of an album by a band called
the insidious blankets
anyway the real issue is that you have
just been accused of being a serial
killer for breathing
every time you walk down the street
breathing you're joining the likes of
john wayne gacy and ted bundy and
you know by the way john wayne gacy and
ted bundy also
they would also breathe i'm told
even hitler could breathe and now you're
breathing
coincidence i think not let's keep
reading it says so far i've been
fortunate
but not a day goes by that i don't
wonder whether my streak of good luck is
about to end
because the person in front of me in the
grocery line is wearing a mask below his
nose
expelling a cloud of radioactive coveted
dust that i cannot escape
short of dropping 50 on the conveyor
belt and trying to outrun the security
guard
so another side note here um are we
going to get a fact check on this
is twitter going to flag this is
facebook going to put on put one of
their
third party fact checkers on the case
radioactive
covid dust that might actually
be another good band name but aside from
that is there any science to this claim
that there's such a thing as covid dust
and that it's radioactive
for that matter is there any science to
the claim that the breath from a
person's nostrils
could carry enough viral load to infect
you if you're standing behind them for
three minutes at the grocery store
where's the science on that well it
doesn't matter you know we know that by
now
the science doesn't matter as long as
what you're saying about covid is scary
if you're saying scary stuff that
that you know that that's that that
terrifies people
it doesn't matter if it's factual or if
there's any evidence if you're saying
stuff that makes covid seem a little
less scary
then you better come to armed with
volumes of studies research medical
charts everything
back to the article it says um it's bad
enough that we have to fear contracting
a deadly virus from a stranger at
t.j.maxx who reaches for the same
decorative throw pillow
what's worse is the brutal reality that
the people we love and trust most in
this world
bring us the same risk more risk because
these are the people with whom we have
regular and close contact
any sustained encounter with those we
love kisses hugs laughs conversations
could bring fever blood cuts clots
fluid-filled lungs and
death okay sidebar again first of all
what kind of man is shopping for
decorative throw pillows
at t.j.maxx this is see that i don't
have to worry about
getting covered while i shop for
decorative throw pillows because i would
never do that
i've always said that the decorative
throw pillow industry would completely
collapse
if all women on earth were raptured you
know into the sky
that industry is done along with the
decorative soap industry
the wrapping paper industry because man
we would just put everything in paper
bags
but apparently this guy is breaking
ranks and he's keeping he's doing his
part to keep the
decorative throw pillow industry going
but more importantly no you don't have
to fear contracting a virus because you
reached for a pillow
you can fear it if you want to you don't
have to
and you shouldn't there are many more
worthwhile things to fear
back to the article it goes on for a
while but this is how he wraps it up he
says
and so as the world eagerly awaits a
vaccine that promises to be rolled out
over the next six months
the wrath of the coronavirus will not
end with inoculation
the way we look at our own survival the
dangers faced by those we love
will be stamped with kovid's dirty
fingerprint for years to come
yeah speak for yourself i can tell you
right now
i didn't learn anything about my own
mortality or about the dangers faced by
those i love
from this i already knew that i was
mortal
i knew that the world is full of dangers
none of that is news to me
but as we recently discussed for those
who have lived their whole lives without
ever
confronting or acknowledging their own
mortality this has i suppose indeed been
a wake-up call
and many of them as we see exhibited
here are not handling it well at all
and that's what this is really about the
author of this delusional
paranoid piece of psychotic
fear-mongering
either had pre-existing mental illnesses
that are now being aggravated during the
covet crisis
or he had lived such a psychologically
sheltered life beforehand
that the existence of a threat any
threat however comparatively mild
is intolerable for him he can't process
it he can't deal with it
yes it's true technically that someone
could
indirectly kill you by breathing too
close to you it's possible that you
could
indirectly kill someone by breathing too
close to them it's also possible that a
rock could fly out of
out of the sky crack open your skull
it's possible that you might get a brain
eating amoeba by jumping into a lake
or even taking a shower did you know
that you know you could get a brain
eating amoeba from from taking a shower
i think
don't quote me on that it's at least
possible
it's a logical possibility it's possible
that the pain in your side is a symptom
of stage four cancer and you'll be dead
in a week
it's possible that somebody will break
into your house and i didn't chop off
your head while you sleep
look a lot of things are possible are
any of them likely
not really some are more likely than
others but the chances in all these
cases are far less than 50
far far far less and so the job of an
adult
human who wants to function in society
and have any chance of being successful
and well adjusted and happy is to keep
all of the terrible possibilities in
proper perspective
and to accept that yes one day a
terrible thing will happen to you a
fatal thing in fact
one day a fatal and terrible thing will
happen to everyone you know and love
your spouse your children everyone you
do have to accept that
you can't function if you don't that
doesn't mean we should be apathetic or
that we should accept or embrace
unreasonable risks
risk it just means that you confront and
acknowledge your mortality
humanity's mortality and go about your
life taking precautions where you can
but never to the point that it causes
you to forfeit all the things that make
living life
worthwhile in the first place
and so on second thought breathing is
not canceled
this paranoid cowardly insane panic porn
is canceled
everybody else is free to go and even to
breathe for now
until the next cancellation at least and
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton